FELIPE HOFFA: Strata,
we need to talk.
Really.
There is a huge debate, and
we need to put an end to it.
And, I mean, people don't know
where to put their commas.
I'm talking about SQL.
I'm sure most of
you must love SQL.
I love SQL.
It's born in 1978.
And it's the one language we--
the best thing we have when
we want to analyze data.
But it's not perfect.
Most of you must have learned
SQL with a sentence like this.
This is how you get
one column of data.
This is how you get two columns.
Then you go for three.
And suddenly, things don't work.
What's wrong here?
That extra comma.
Yes, you've been there.
SQL will not allow you to
put a hanging comma there,
unlike any other
modern language.
And this has driven people
to two different camps--
there are people that put
their commas at the end;
people that put their
commas at the beginning.
Who likes their
commas at the end?
Who likes their commas
at the beginning?
You monsters!
That's ugly!
Well, I'm one of you.
I like to put my commas
at the beginning.
I find it more productive.
But it's hard to convince
people about this.
So I happen to work at Google
where we make decisions
based on data.
Also, I work for
Google Cloud platform
where we share our best
tools with everyone.
So things that we
use internally,
you are also able to use.
And one of them is BigQuery.
With BigQuery, we can analyze
not only terabytes of data
in seconds, we are
also able to share data
within our teammates, within
third parties, publicly.
And we love using it to
collaborate, to discuss,
to take the same data and
reach conclusions together.
In this case, for example,
I have all of Github's data,
started a query.
And with a query
like this, I can
see how many events
Github has seen
this year, 350 million events.
I can join this table
with other tables.
I can bring in,
for example, count
the number of distinct users,
active users this year.
And I can bring another table to
see where are they coming from,
what are the most popular
countries on Github--
the United States,
China, India--
which we would call
an unfair ranking.
I mean, these are the
biggest countries.
Of course, they
have the most users.
So let's bring in more tables.
Let's bring in more data.
Let's get the countries that
have the most Github users
per capita.
And now we have countries
like Iceland, Sweden, Norway,
on top--
cold countries.
Or not.
So now we can
bring in more data.
We can join this with the warm
weather data that we have in.
And we can get a
chart like this,
which shows that, yes,
the coldest countries, up
on the top left, are the
ones with the highest
concentration of programmers,
the opposite on the other side.
But if you look at that
point on the top right,
that's Singapore.
Yes, Singapore, you have
the highest concentration
of programmers on Github
within the hot countries.
Congratulations.
But let me get back
to our problem--
where do we put our commas?
And this is not
tabs versus spaces.
This really matters.
And I'm going to bring in all
code I can find on Github.
I'm going to analyze
gigabytes of SQL code,
and I will use it to
count the number of lines
that end with a comma,
start with a comma.
And the results show that
most lines end with a comma.
I lost.
Or not.
Because the real question
is, what projects
are more successful?
How do we measure that?
The number of stars, the
number of stars last year,
the number of contributors, the
activity, et cetera, et cetera.
We can define our success
metrics, and we can measure,
and we can write a query.
We can get the
results in seconds.
And it basically
says that projects
that allow leading people
to write leading commas
are double as productive
as the others.
It's true.
You can go and measure it
in any measure you want.
Thank you, yes.
You were the
leading comma group.
So my message here is that maybe
it will not stop our fights.
Because I'm sure I didn't
convince everyone here.
Someone will ask about
correlation, causation.
How do you-- are
you measuring this?
Why an average?
And the whole point is
that you can fight me.
You can use the same tools.
You can use the same
queries and data,
and analyze it, and fight me.
Some people we'll never
convince no matter how much data
we show them.
We call them industry analysts.
Sorry.
But, yes, at least we should
embrace data in this fight.